sarah palin former alaska governor and
2008 vice presidential nominee for the
republicans she is running for congress
as we know she's trying to make a
comeback into public life after a long
hiatus and she has now passed the first
hurdle for getting the job this is
actually a special election that's going
on in alaska since don young died
earlier this year after representing the
at-large district in alaska for 49 years
now alaska has this interesting system
where they have all of their candidates
regardless of party appear on the same
ballot for a first round of voting the
top four vote getters then move on to
the next round of voting where ranked
choice voting is used to determine who
comes out on top we just had the first
round of voting and we're still getting
the votes in but as of now the results
show that palin has 29.8 percent of the
vote followed by another republican
named nick begich at 19.3 percent then
we have al gross at 12.5 percent and
democrat mary pelota at seven point five
percent so those should be the four who
advance and move on to the second round
notably not making the cut yet still
getting an impressive 4.5 percent of the
vote was democratic socialist candidate
santa claus which i didn't realize that
santa lived up in alaska i thought he
lived up in canada or like maybe the
international territory that makes up
the north pole but apparently he's an
alaska resident and who knows maybe
he'll get him next time palin's near 30
in the vote is a commanding uh lead
ahead of everyone else but then when you
note that there's something like 50
other candidates you have to think about
how the other voters are going to
coalesce when the
candidate number drops down to four
also you have ranked choice voting so
that makes it a little bit harder to
predict compared to a normal election so
who knows what will happen in the second
round uh you just don't know who people
are going to coalesce around maybe the
other republican will do better in the
second round maybe the independent al
gross will win there's a good chance
that maybe she's not able to pull this
thing off and that would of course be a
major blow to trump's endorsement record
and to the state of trumpism in this
country because not only is palin
endorsed by trump she in a lot of ways
was trump before trump was trump notably
based on how incompetent and
inarticulate she was and we didn't
realize that someone so unqualified
could serve in public office at such a
high level but you know then we got
donald trump and now it's somewhat
normalized also not helping palin and
trump is the fact that alaska politics
are a lot different than the rest of the
country they tend to be more centrist
and they like the more reasonable
candidates more often than not so
who knows if she can pull it off there
it's really just not the reddest state
in the country plus many alaskans view
palin as a quitter because she quit her
job as governor
10 plus years back to do a reality tv
show so that just didn't sit very well
with them how do they know that she's
not going to resign early from her seat
in congress but fear not because palin
has an excellent excuse in her back
pocket in case she doesn't come out on
top she went on mark levin's show a few
weeks ago
and she said that you know if i don't
win uh clearly it's because of voter
fraud yeah she's using that routine
let's take a look at this clip from
about a month ago yeah whether i have a
a good shot or not they're they're i
think about 50 candidates in this race
it's a real bizarre race and there's
ballot
50 and um
mark you'll just really appreciate this
it's mail in only ballots uh no hand
counting to tabulate got to go through a
dominion
computer to count everything and
i like yesterday mark i received four
ballots in the mail i didn't even ask
for any ballots uh one for one of the
daughters who doesn't live here
she has hasn't claimed residency in
alaska since she moved outside
we call anything outside of alaska i'm
trying to say murkowski
well um you know who wrote this bizarre
election plan that we have right now
going on with the ranked choice voting
that's coming up and the mail and only
ballots and all that was lisa
murkowski's attorney
i believe
well yeah i mean do i do i have a shot
at it yeah i i have a shot at it um
it's it's
bizarre though you know
this kind of voting system so i hope the
rest of america keeps track of what's
going on in alaska so it doesn't happen
to them well that's certainly the
trumpian playbook right there if you win
everything was on the up and up and you
just got more votes from the good people
of your district to your state but if
you lose you didn't really lose it was
just rigged and what can you do you were
a victim so that's nice you have that in
your back pocket as an excuse and you
can really use it in any election that
you want to of course i want palin to be
defeated and there's really a good
chance of that happening we'll have to
see it's going to be tight but maybe
this is a race that we can get ourselves
involved in but part of me wonders like
if sarah palin does become a congress
person would that have entertainment
value would she have these wacky off the
rail speeches on the house floor that
would be worth watching i also wonder if
she would
interact well with people like marjorie
taylor green and lauren beaubert would
she be too crazy for them would they be
too crazy for her i just don't know so
you know if she does end up pulling off
the win in this race that will be like
the one saving grace we get to see how
she functions as a member of congress
but hopefully it doesn't get to that and
hopefully sarah palin is defeated when
it's time for the second round of voting
of course there'll be more elections to
come and we'll be following all of them
all right thanks very much to david for
allowing me to host today's show and uh
if you want to check out the bonus show
make sure to become a member at
joinpacman.com or go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow and contribute at the
five dollar level i'll see you there